Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Neun Spieltage sind in der 2. Bundesliga der Männer schon absolviert. Und wir wollen mal wieder genauer draufblicken, diesen Spieltag Revue passieren lassen und uns ein bisschen Zeit nehmen für Hannover 96 und den FCK. Hallo und herzlich willkommen in Rasenfunk Kurzpass Nr. 229. Wie ihr gehört habt, wollen wir sprechen über die 2. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost, ich bin der Ed Genetzer auf Twitter und freue mich, mich hier begrüßen zu dürfen. Zwei wunderbare Podcast-Stimmen, also allein akustisch wird das ein Gedicht. Ich begrüße hier Tobias Rieger, der Ed Runner Tobi. Ihr kennt ihn vielleicht von der MSP-WG auf meinsportpodcast.de. Hallo Tobi, schön, dass du mal wirklich hier bist.
Hallo aus Hannover. Vielen Dank für die Einladung, Max.
Ja, das wird total ungewohnt, dass wir mal eine Sendung miteinander machen, wo wir kein Martin-Kind-Trinkspiel draus machen müssen, weil wir irgendwie dreißigmal diesen Arm fallen lassen.
Da musste er sehr genau seine Worte nochmal wählen. Ich habe so ein bisschen das Gefühl, Sebastian, dass der FCK ein bisschen die dritte Liga mitgebracht hat in die zweite Liga, wenn ich das so höre.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Wir müssen gleich aber auch nochmal bei Tobi nachfragen, was es mit seiner Meinung zu Dirk Schuster auf sich hat. Da kommen wir nicht drum herum. Aber da hast du durchaus recht. Ich glaube, die Mannschaft hat zum einen diesen Schwung aus der dritten Liga und vor allem auch aus der Relegation gegen Dresden mitnehmen können, die Euphorie mitnehmen können und so ein bisschen auch die Spielweise. Wobei ich glaube, dieses Dreckige, das ist nicht unbedingt nur was, was charakteristisch für die dritte Liga ist, sondern das ist eigentlich genau dieser FCK-Fußball, den die Leute auch sehen wollen. Ich will jetzt nicht sagen, die Leute wollen sehen, dass die FCK-Jungs ständig irgendeinen umtreten, aber die wollen halt einfach sehen, dass sich reingeworfen wird, dass auch einem eigentlich schon verloren geglaubten Ball hinterhergegrätscht und gerannt wird. Von daher ist es jetzt auch wenig überraschend, dass der FCK die Kartentabelle quasi anführt. Aber wenn das der Weg zum Erfolg für den FCK ist, dann ist das, glaube ich, was alle, die da irgendwie was zu sagen haben, gerne unterschreiben würden. Aber wie gesagt, noch mal der Schwenk zurück zu Tobi und zu Dirk Schuster.
Ich habe das ja bewusst so formuliert. Ich sage mal so, Dirk Schuster ist jetzt nicht zwingend einer der Trainer, die ich mir für Hannover 96 wünsche. Als Kassas Lautern den dann kurz vor Saisonende verpflichtet hat, da habe ich gedacht, da ist Hannover 96 jetzt aber noch mal mit einem blauen Auge davongekommen, dass sie ihn nicht kriegen in der Sommerpause, dass das mit Leitl so geklappt hat, wie es geplant war. Von daher, ich weiß nicht, der überzeugt mich nicht so ganz. Aber aufgestiegen, schon mehrfach, von daher alles gut. Ich beobachte das wirklich mit großen Augen.
Ich meine, wir müssen auch nicht um den Drumherum reden, dass die Begeisterung, als Dirk Schuster für Marco Antwerpen kam, alles andere als groß war. Also man muss sich das nochmal –das ist jetzt lange her, und ich will da jetzt auch nicht einen zu großen Ausflug in die Vergangenheit machen –aber man muss sich nochmal deutlich machen, dass Marco Antwerpen ein unfassbar gutes Standing bei den FCK-Fans hatte und es quasi –also hier ist quasi die Hölle losgebrochen, die ja sehr gut zum FCK und zum Betzenberg auch passt. Als es dann hieß, Marco Antwerpen ist nicht mehr länger FCK-Trainer und Dirk Schuster kommt jetzt, da gab es eigentlich –da hast du, glaube ich, keine Handvoll Leute gefunden, die das gut fanden. Von daher, wenn ich mich jetzt sehr positiv über ihn bisher geäußert habe, dann ist das einfach das, was die Mannschaft bisher zeigt und was mein Eindruck ist. Aber der Start war durchaus schwierig. Natürlich hat ihm dann die erfolgreiche Relegation recht gegeben und total in die Karten gespielt. Aber es wird sich dann eben auch zeigen –wir können alle gespannt sein, wie lange der FCK diese Euphorie weiter mitnehmen kann, wie lange er weiter auf dieser Welle schwappen kann. Und irgendwann, spätestens in der Rückrunde, ist man dann auch mal im harten, zweitläger Alltag angekommen. Dann werden wir mal sehen, wohin die Reise geht. Das ist ja schon was, die Leute drehen hier auch schon wieder durch. Das ist dieses typische, was man auch immer hört, das viel zitierte, schwierige Umfeld. Die Leute werden total schnell nervös, aber auch total schnell euphorisch. Also wenn da mal zwei, drei Spiele verloren wurden, dann ist wieder alles schlecht. Das ist wahrscheinlich bei vielen Vereinen so, aber in Lautern ist das auch so. Das kann ich überhaupt nicht, aber genauso schnell verfällt man rund um den Betzenberg in die Euphorie und damals, als dieser Luxemburger Investor kam, wurde ja schnell vom Thema Champions League gesprochen und jetzt träumt wirklich der ein oder andere davon, dass der FC Kader den Durchmarsch packt und wieder in die Bundesliga aufsteigt. Das ist einfach vor allem nach dieser harten Zeit in der dritten Liga, das wäre einfach too much. Also das wäre einfach zu viel des Guten. Das wäre, glaube ich, kein gesunder Weg. Klar, wenn man jetzt am Ende des Tages dann da steht und sagt, wir stehen jetzt überm Strich und steigen auf, dann werden sie sicher auch nicht sagen, ne, machen wir nicht. Aber man ist echt gut beraten. Natürlich ist es super und es ist ein super Pfund, was man da hat, dass die Leute, dass diese Welle von Sympathie und Euphorie diesen Verein so sehr trägt, aber man ist, glaube ich, echt gut beraten und das machen die Verantwortlichen beim FC Kader auch, da so ein bisschen auf die Bremse zu treten und die backen da auch alle zumindest nach außen hin, kleinere Brötchen und betonen immer wieder, dass nur der nicht-abstieg des Saisons sie sein kann, auch wenn ich selber glaube, dass sie innerlich ein bisschen was anderes wollen, auch aufgrund dessen, was da außen rum so passiert und der Investoren, die da so am Start sind und wie viel Geld die da reinstecken, aber das ist wieder ein anderes Thema.
Das ist allerdings wieder ein anderes Thema. Und wer weiß, vielleicht müssen wir gar nicht auf die Rückrunde warten, bis wir sehen, was passiert, wenn die Euphoriewelle weg ist. Vielleicht müssen wir einfach nur warten, bis die ersten Gelbsperren reinknallen. Der Eric Dome hat schon vier Gelbekarten, Tom Jagd Zimmer und Lobinger jeweils drei. Also das wird jetzt nicht mehr allzu lange dauern. Da lehne ich mich jetzt nicht allzu weit aus dem Fenster. Wir haben jetzt schon recht viel besprochen, aber ich möchte doch noch ganz kurz mit dir über Thomas Hengen sprechen, weil du hast ihn vorhin kurz angesprochen. Der sportliche Geschäftsführer war ja früher mal Kapitän, dann bei Aachen als Sportdirektor im Einsatz und hat auch schon als Scout und Kaderplaner gearbeitet, für Everton, für den HSV, für West Ham United und PSV Eindhoven. Und ehrlich gesagt, all diese letzten Dinge, die waren mir überhaupt nicht mehr geläufig. Also das musste ich mir alles erst wieder erarbeiten. Welche Rolle spielt er beim jetzigen Erfolg und was ist er für ein Typ?
Also man kann glaube ich ganz klar sagen, dass Thomas Hengen ein absoluter Glücksgriff ist für den ersten FC Kaiserslautern. Er wird auch ganz gerne von den Fans, gerade auch bei Twitter in der sogenannten Betze Timeline, sehr, sehr gefeiert für seine Transfers, die er jetzt auch wieder getätigt hat, wird da gerne auch mal als Don Hengen bezeichnet, weil es ihm ja tatsächlich auch gelungen ist, den ein oder anderen, ich will nicht sagen Kracher zu verpflichten, aber ich meine, also sind wir mal ehrlich, dass ein Andi Lute auf den Betzenberg gekommen ist, damit hätten glaube ich die wenigsten gerechnet. Natürlich ist er schon in seinem Fußballer Herbst, aber dass der noch mal den Schritt zum FCK geht, okay, Eric Durm genauso, also der hat schon den ein oder anderen Transfer an Land gezogen, wo man sagen muss, Respekt, klar, da sind im Hintergrund, die eben schon angesprochenen Investoren, die da auch Geld geben und solche Dinge dann ermöglichen, aber ich glaube genau das, was du auch angesprochen hast, was dir nicht mehr so geläufig war, diese Arbeit von Thomas Heng, bevor er beim FCK war, als Scout und auch international tätig, in England tätig, ich glaube, das kommt ihm jetzt auch zu Gute. Ich glaube, dass er einfach in der Zeit ein sehr, sehr gutes Netzwerk aufgebaut hat. Ich glaube, dass er in der Zeit einfach sehr, sehr viel gelernt hat, dass er so ein bisschen weg vom Radar in Deutschland war, auch dann in Aachen. Das war ja jetzt nichts, bei allem Respekt vor allem an Aachen, aber das war jetzt nichts, was in der breiten Öffentlichkeit besonders stark beobachtet wurde. Aber ich glaube, dass er davon jetzt eben zehrt, dass er jetzt eben seine Qualitäten ausspielen kann. Und was er geschafft hat, ist, er hat eine unglaubliche Ruhe auch reingebracht in dieses zuvor sehr, sehr unruhige Umfeld. Also was für uns Journalisten ziemlich kacke ist, aber für den Verein gut ist das, was Thomas Hengen gemacht hat. Es kommt so gut wie nichts mehr nach draußen, auch was Transfergerüchte angeht. Also man hat Dinge erst sehr, sehr spät kurz vor Abschluss mitbekommen und generell dringt sehr, sehr wenig aus dem innersten Kreis des 1. FCKs das Lautern mittlerweile nach draußen. Und das ist, was der FCK bitter nötig gehabt hat, weil es da sehr, sehr viele schmutzige Grabenkämpfe gab in den letzten Jahren. Und das hat Thomas Hengen geschafft. Und man muss ja –ich weiß, wir sind schon lange drauf, was das Thema angeht. Das muss ich aber auch noch sagen. Man muss ja auch sagen, Thomas Hengen ist ja mittlerweile quasi alleiniger Boss beim FCK. Also er hat ja eigentlich mal noch einen kaufmännischen Kollegen an der Seite gehabt und macht das ja mittlerweile alleine und ist quasi nicht nur Sportchef, sondern komplett FCK-Chef. Von daher, ja, Hut ab, wie er das alles meistert. Und er hat den Laden echt im Griff, muss man sagen.
Absolut, also beim FCK läuft es gerade sehr, sehr gut und es dringt wenig nach außen. Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie ich jetzt die Überleitung zum HSV und Fortuna Düsseldorf bauen soll, deswegen gehe ich einfach nicht den einfachen Weg und sage, das ist das letzte Spiel, über das wir noch sprechen wollen. Der HSV, der als Tabellenführer diesen Spieltag beschließen darf, unter anderem, weil man gegen Fortuna Düsseldorf zu Hause mit 2 zu 0 gewinnt. Die Tore machen Jatta in der Nachspielzeit und Robert Glatzl in der 21. Minute. Und damit steht der HSV, Tobi, nicht nur bei 21 Punkten nach 9 Spielen, hat siebenmal gewonnen, zweimal verloren, sondern man hat auch die wirklich beeindruckende Torbilanz von 14 zu 5 Toren. Also man ist unglaublich defensiv stark da in Hamburg.
Ja, und das war mein Live-Spiel dieses Wochenende. Ich war vor Ort im Stadion, habe es mir angeguckt. Und ich muss sagen, auch im Hinblick darauf, dass der nächste Gegner vom HSV, Hannover 96, ist, ich war schon ein bisschen, das hat mich so ein bisschen angespannt, die ganze Geschichte. Die haben das schon echt gut gemacht, die Hamburger. Das hat Spaß gemacht, denen zuzugucken. Die müssen eigentlich schon 2-0 führen, bevor sie überhaupt das 1-0 machen. Hatten da Chancen, das Ding an die Latte geknallt und all solche Geschichten. Und spielen einfach einen richtig, richtig schönen Ball. Also dieses 1 zu 0, ich glaube, Vuskovic war es, der so einen Außenristpass als Eröffnung nach außen spielt, wo Jatta dann steht, abgeht, den Ball reinflankt und da steht dann Glatzel und macht den komplett humorlos rein. Das hat mich schon sehr, sehr beeindruckt. Und ich glaube, dass das mit den wenigen Gegentoren, zumindest gegen Düsseldorf, auch ein gutes Stück an Düsseldorf lag. Denn nach dem 2 zu 0 ist das Spiel dann insgesamt so in der zweiten, nicht nach dem zweiten, nach der Halbzeit. Nach der Halbzeit ist das Spiel dann insgesamt so ein bisschen verflacht, hatte ich das Gefühl. Man hat sich eher Richtung Düsseldorf orientiert, Düsseldorf nicht Richtung Hamburg, was die Leistung angeht. Und so sah die zweite Halbzeit dann auch aus. Also Hamburg hat das irgendwie so weggespielt. Also die waren schon besser und auch dominant, aber jetzt nicht mehr so wirklich zwingend. Und haben vielleicht auch ein bisschen versäumt, den Sack ein Stückchen früher zuzumachen. Das war ja dann erst die 90. als Jatta das Tor gemacht hat. Aber ich glaube, dass sie keine Tore gegen Düsseldorf gekriegt haben, war an dem Tag auch viel Düsseldorfs Unvermögen. Weil die haben mich im Gegensatz zur restlichen Saison am Samstagabend nicht überzeugt.
Am Ende nur drei Schüsse für Düsseldorf, kein einziger Aufs-Tor. Das ist dann doch schon sehr, sehr deutlich in der Torschuss-Statistik. Also den Schuss ein Aufs-Tor. Da hat Hamburg ein 8 zu 0. Und da ist dann so das Endergebnis von 2 zu 0 auch nicht mehr so ganz überraschend. Sebastian, kannst du erklären, was da los war mit der Fortuna?
Nee, ich kann es dir nicht beantworten, Max. Ich kann dir nicht sagen, woran das bei der Fortuna liegt. Hab aber auch ehrlicherweise zu wenig von der Fortuna bislang gesehen in der Saison. Vielleicht war es einfach die Angst vom großen HSV, der ihn da Angst eingejagt hat, weil er ja zum Aufstieg verdammt ist, sozusagen. Aber nee, ich glaube, da war einfach nach vorne viel zu wenig von der Fortuna zu sehen, in dem Spiel bis auf den Abseits-Tor, was aber auch klar abseits war. Und ja, der HSV auf der anderen Seite hat halt individuelle Klasse, das hat man gesehen. Gerade auch bei dem 1 zu 0, da ist die Vorarbeit eigentlich schöner als das Tor an sich. Auch was der Jatta da macht, wie der den Ball mitnimmt und dann vorlegt für Glatzel, das ist echt erste Sahne. Und dann hast du halt auch nochmal Qualität, die von der Bank reinkommt, mit Kittel, der halt wirklich auch nochmal echt Alarm gemacht hat und auch sehr schön vorgelegt hat, das 2 zu 0 für Jatta. Von daher, ja, ich glaube der HSV steht nicht unverdient da, wo er steht.
Ich finde die Fortuna gar nicht so schlecht. Also, das war, wie gesagt, Samstag, das war eher nix. Das hat mich jetzt nicht so beeindruckt. Und vielleicht können wir es tatsächlich auf den HSV und die stabile Defensive schieben, dass sie gar nicht so viel zugelassen haben an dem Tag. Aber Düsseldorf spielt keine schlechte Saison. Also, man darf nicht vergessen, wenn die das Spiel gewinnen, sind die einen Punkt an den HSV ran. Das würde nicht das Spiel widerspiegeln, aber jetzt sind es natürlich sieben Punkte Rückstand. Deshalb sieht das alles ein bisschen größer aus, was die Lücke angeht. Aber insgesamt spielt Düsseldorf keine schlechte Saison. Also, sie haben so ein bisschen so eine komische Phase gehabt. Da haben sie in Sandhausen verloren, 1-0, 2-2 zu Hause gegen Fürth, die da noch sieglos und so weiter waren, und 2-2 gegen Eintracht Braunschweig. Für die galt das Gleiche. Das war so der Moment, wo sie nicht so ganz genau wussten, glaube ich, wo es hingeht. Aber drum herum ist das okay. Also, man kann in Heidenheim verlieren, man kann in Hamburg verlieren. Das passiert ganz anderen Mannschaften und ist völlig in Ordnung. Aber sie gewinnen halt gegen Regensburg. Sie haben den Auftakt gut gestaltet mit einem Sieg in Magdeburg und haben auch Paderborn zu Hause 2 zu 1 geschlagen. Und Paderborn, damit die einzige Niederlage der Saison –nein, das stimmt nicht, eine von zwei Niederlagen der Saison beigefügt –also ich finde, wir sollten nicht zu schlecht über Düsseldorf reden, nur weil das jetzt in Hamburg nicht gut war. Und das wird, wie gesagt, noch ganz, ganz anderen Vereinen ebenfalls so gehen.
Ich glaube, das bindet es wunderbar ab. Und ich glaube, das bindet auch diesen kompletten Spieltag und diese Spieltagsbesprechung ab. Ich danke euch sehr, sehr herzlich. Das hat große Freude gemacht, mit euch nicht nur auf diesen Spieltag zu blicken, sondern auch noch ein bisschen genauer auf Hannover 96 und den 1. FC Kaiserslautern. Ich danke ganz herzlich Sebastian Zobel vom SWR und dem Nur der FCK Podcast, den ich sehr empfehlen kann, at twitch.redo mit drei O's auf Twitter. Danke dir, lieber Sebastian, dass du wieder mal hier im Rasenfunk warst.
Danke dir, Max. Vielen, vielen Dank und auch vielen, vielen Dank an Tobi.
Ja, da schließe ich mich an. Auch ich möchte Tobi danken. Tobi Rieger, der at runner Tobi, auf Twitter. Ihr kennt ihn natürlich aus der MeinSportPodcast-WG. Danke dir, Tobi, dass du mal wieder im Rasenfunk warst. Und wie schön das war, dass wir einfach mal über Sport reden konnten.
Danke für die Einladung, Max. Auch danke an Hannover 96 und auch an die 2. Liga, dass es so ein attraktiver Spieltag war mit 31 Toren. Das hat wirklich was hergemacht. Wir hatten, glaube ich, keine Probleme, Punkte zu finden, die irgendwie interessant waren. Und natürlich auch vielen Dank und beste Grüße an Sebastian.
Ach, ist das hier harmonisch. Das ist ja nicht zum aushalten. Liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, gebt uns doch mal Feedback, wie ihr jetzt dieses Format mit der Spielbesprechung fandet, im Abgrenzung zu zuletzt, wo wir immer über Vereine gesprochen haben, aber dann eben auch nicht alle erwähnt wurden. Unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de oder in den sozialen Netzwerken könnt ihr uns Feedback geben und hört auch die anderen Kurzpässe, unter anderem zum ersten Spieltag in der Frauen-Bundesliga und wenn ihr wollt, noch die Schlusskonferenz zum siebten Spieltag in der Männer-Bundesliga. Mein Gott, es gibt viel zu hören! Bis bald hier im Rasenfunk.